[Music]
the european economy is rebounding
swiftly from the pandemic induced
recession
as vaccinations progressed and
restrictions
gradually lifting starting in the spring
growth resumed more strongly than
expected
pent-up demand and rapidly increasing
private consumption
are driving growth as the economy
reopens
highs household savings
and an improving labor market should
continue supporting consumer confidence
investments is set to benefit from this
strong domestic demand
and from the impulse of next generation
eu
the acceleration in economic activity
saw many workers exiting job retention
schemes
unemployment has decreased
nearing its pre-pandemic rates
but the jobs rebound is not happening
evenly across sectors and economies
so the risk of worsening inequality
between genders
age groups and sections of society
remains real
deficits in 2021 are said to be lower
than expected in spring
and to decline markedly in 22 and 23. as
emergency support measures unwind
while strong demand is driving the
recovery
problems in global supply chains and
logistics are holding back activity in
several sectors more recently
a sharp increase in energy prices
particularly for natural gas has also
weighed on the economic outlook and as a
result
we are seeing a sweet pickup in
inflation
these global headwinds
are said to be a temporary
phenomenon and we expect them to abate
over the forecast horizon
however
the pace of the recovery will still be
influenced by the evolution of the
kovite 19 pandemic
marked differences in vaccination rates
globally are a key concern
especially given the emergence of new
more contagious variants
in short
we are leaving behind the worst economic
crisis in decades but continued support
from governments and the eu
will remain essential for the recovery
to gain traction
and for the european economy to progress
towards strong and sustainable growth
you